dawn break in on another tense day in
westminster everyone here wondering
whether we'll soon have a broken prime
minister too
out of the front door but the pm already
on the back foot
[Music]
head into parliament to fight for his
political life
before he even gets there an
extraordinary moment as one of his
former mps executes a body blow
former red wall mp christian wakeford
defecting to labour
sitting behind his new leader after
giving up on boris johnson scores of his
former tory colleagues contemplating
giving up on the pm2 angry over the
ongoing allegations this week he's got a
new defense
nobody warned me that it was against the
rules
since the prime minister wrote the walls
why on earth does he think this new
defense is going to work for him not
having any of it the pm today trying to
get back on the attack when the history
of this pandemic comes to be written and
the history of the labour party comes to
be written and believe me they are
history and will remain history mr
speaker
it will show it will show it will show
that we delivered while they dithered
gathering himself up after a bruising
few days even as calls for his
resignation roll in waving it all away
but then came this a significant moment
much harder to ignore i expect my
leaders
to shoulder the responsibility
for the actions they take
yesterday he did the opposite of that
so i'll remind him of a quotation
altogether too familiar to him of leo
amory to neville chamberlain you have
sat there too long for all the good you
have done in the name of god go
and there were times today he was
desperate to leave this chamber check in
his watch as the blows rained down
[Music]
the common speaker not wrong quite the
day
losing an mp to the opposition is
momentous when
it's getting to a point where it's
difficult to
explain some of these issues then you
know it's wrong
and at the moment you know we've got
party trying to defend being defensible
they're doing so gladly the toxicity of
the johnson regime now polluting
different wings of the parliamentary
party
but mps i've spoken to today in this
place also tell me that these public
attacks have in a way help shore up
support behind the prime minister in the
short term at least but even his allies
admit to me they don't know if he's on
borrowed time and they're wondering if
and when that confidence vote could come
one of the 2019 intake in a prized red
wool seat urging colleagues to wait i'd
say to any of my colleagues who are
thinking about this at the moment i'd
say wait for the sugray report because
we need to have established facts
anything that happens now is going to be
there before we have an accepted version
of what's gone on and we need to have
that before we move
a calmer end to another stormy day but
the pm still in danger and the prospect
of that no-confidence ballot still very
real beth rigby sky news westminster
you